comment ils sont actuellement j'ai pu
l'être un coeur qui bat à katmandou
échographe y est depuis bauges c'est une
première mondiale en matière de
télémédecine élaboré grâce à la volonté
du professeur philippe arbeille de
l'hôpital trousseau de tours est mise au
point par des chercheurs de l'iut et de
l'école d'ingénieurs de bourges
on ne dispose pas toujours deux mains
expertes pour tenir la sonde
donc on avait l'idée d'avoir un centre
expert avec un médecin spécialiste en
échographie qui pourraient télé
manipuler la sonde d'échographie à
travers le robot ou que soit le
l'échographe en question que ce soit sur
un bord de route
après un accident dans un hôpital
périphériques qui n'est pas qui n'a pas
spécifié d'échographie et c est ce qu
ils font de leur argent soit encore une
autre
grâce au satellite et aux réseaux
numériques la sonde échographique qui se
trouve au népal est pilotée à partir de
ce vil commandes et l'on comprend mieux
le dispositif en regardant ses effets en
laboratoire le robot et placerez sur le
corps du sujet la sonde s'oriente selon
les ordres donnés par ordinateur tandis
que l'image échographique s'inscrit sur
l'écran
ensuite au niveau retombées donc on va
essayer de rentrer dans un projet
européen pour la station spatiale pour
avoir des financements pour avoir un
appareil beaucoup plus performant et
puis à plus long terme on peut envisager
aussi une implantation dans des centres
médicaux relié avec un centre régional
avec un espoir à partir de ces premiers
essais réussis les chercheurs vont
pouvoir affiner le dispositif est testé
le principe en milieu hospitalier
dès cette année